welcome everyone to the first annual JK
Hunger Games
[Music]
you guys are welcome to hangout songs
look at this [__] tactical ass [__]
see you see this [__] look at this this
guy's got ready for some bsdm [__]
[__] right here look at that oh I'm
gonna put Jill handcuffs you see some
[__] [__] right here yeah let's
do it let's do it yeah
around three four years ago when we were
young boys we had a lot of Adventures
that were also planned we had it on JK
party we had it on JK films and we just
randomly chose an excuse we were like we
need to film this [__] for Content but
in reality we just wanted to find a way
to go hang out with each other after all
these years I think this is our 16th
year on YouTube it just blows my mind
how many Die Hard fans that have been
watching I would say most of our viewers
out there they've been watching for
years like we don't have fans that many
fans that have been watching for a few
months like if you ask almost all of
them are like oh I've been watching
since junior high I'm a full-grown adult
like pediatrician now I'm like 76 years
old and I've been watching you since
junior high and that's a really cool
thing because especially digital media
like whether it's YouTube or whatever
the fan base is fickle people don't roll
with you for like a long time so I think
we're like a special case why are we
still interesting like how can we still
get to survive I don't know but I just
feel grateful about it and also since my
store has opened in Honolulu out in
Waikiki when my juby's there I'm
actually working the shop because we got
a worker shortage I haven't been able to
do any meet and greets or shows so I
kind of forget right like when you're
pumping out videos you have numbers
behind the screen you don't really get
to see the humans behind that and when
we had our grand opening and we just had
this like full Rush of people from
locals from people just visiting Hawaii
they all like make it a point to drop by
I get to meet everybody face to face and
that's really mind-blowing to me some
people are like hey like me and my wife
we met each other over JK and then now
they got kids and [__] and I'm like what
that's [__] crazy like you use that
to get in a [__] that's cool man I'm
glad you got laid through JK all those
things I feel like it's crazy like how
long this is going on and I'm wondering
now like how long will it go on for like
35 days or something 35 days until we go
through this I give it 36 yeah okay yeah
I give I have a little more faith in our
fans let's bet 36 days until JK dies all
right we just finished shooting some
Airsoft old school JK style how JK news
was even born is after events we would
all go hang out and eat and talk and
we're at a sgv stable Joe found it long
10 so I started coming here because we
grew up here and this place didn't
really exist When We Were Young we
usually go to other cafes but today I
was like there's a new Hong Kong Cafe in
town I don't really know if it's truly
Hong Kong but it has some of the things
I grew up with it's on pepper pork chops
salt and pepper wings salt pepper
calamari salt pepper everything you know
that's authentic so that's why I was
like let's go and we're gonna order
family Styles we share a bunch of the
food we've been eating here for quite
some time so we just wanted to bring
everybody does anyone have any allergies
they should have spoke up a while ago
all right so we got what BART calls a
meat gummy bear it is like a candied
filet mignon
it's so soft I got this thing it's a
it's a apple it's called rice
[Music]
it was jasmine rice this right here is
called beef chow fun
because when you child you have a lot of
fun
right here we got the white person hair
you know you cut off a head of a blind
person you eat it
thank you
that's called Shanghai mud
this is a nice gesture after Bart making
me eat stinky tofu what so I considered
reparations is it better than sink tofu
a little bit yeah I love this place you
can't go wrong with this stuff I mean
like anytime you come to like a Hong
Kong style Cafe like this there's always
hitters dude everything's fried can't go
wrong fried rice noodles we got French
toast I even know they have french toast
here yeah one of our friends for Joe's
birthday he like did zero physical
activity yeah and so they're playing
Airsoft and he's there and as soon as he
like he's crouching he stood up his cap
just like [__] okay yeah and we saw
him like go oh guys
before
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was a really good dinner oh yeah
that was really nice because we don't
really get to do these Adventures on a
regular we have to plan them months in
advance so uh tonight was a really
special night because we used to go out
and eat on a regular like seven days a
week but now you know it's not even it's
not it's not very easy to do that yeah
once every seven months yeah if there's
any cool ideas that you'd like to see us
go on let us know in the comments below
maybe that'll be in our next JK
Adventure until next time
peace hey maybe next time we could go to
a law office here
that's flaming all right
[Music]